[Music]
what's up how you livin how you feelin
LEF koe man here with the sharpest man
in football warren sharp you can always
find his stuff on sharp football
analysis calm which by the way three and
one last week on the free week including
a riveting Monday Night Football game
that had me and Warren texting each
other like 15 21 year old recently abled
gamblers and and really if you bet the
over and you took the Seahawks the
reason it hit it was because of Warren's
new shoes so Warren you know you can say
to everybody right now you're welcome
for the over because you were those
lucky shoes you that actually pushed it
to four and one hitting that one and
excuse me excuse me it was it was the it
was the new Odell's the the tuxedo
Odell's yes so Warren sent me a picture
he's like I just put these on and then
all of a sudden it was like 49ers
defense have touched down Russell Wilson
incredible third down play and we just
kept texted and you but like at one
point I thought Warren took the shoes
off and I got very angry and yeah he was
like no I didn't take him off and then
they missed the field goal it was
perfect yeah no it was III was
continuing to rock him I said next time
I'm up there which I was supposed to be
up there today but we were pushing that
back so we're gonna do a doubleheader in
the postseason but yeah next time I'm up
there I'm where I'm showcasing them the
other thing that I I think Warren and I
have been sharing but also disagreeing
on is I told Warren yesterday man it is
brick in New York City right now and he
goes oh you mean the hawk and so I think
this is a regional thing where brick I
believe is the perfect way to describe
what's going on in New York right now
because it feels as though if you took a
cool brick and you put it against your
face that's what it feels like there's
this thing that happens in New York
Warren where like the city preemptively
salt down and so all the streets turn
white and it makes it feel like it's
colder than it is but right now brick
and how would you describe the hawk like
what is the hawk Hawk is out Hawk is
just like it's it's coming for you it's
windy it's cold it's blustery you want
to avoid the hawk its swooping yeah hmm
so yeah I find they're different you can
use both I don't when it's windy I don't
think it's brick I think it's brick when
you walk out and it's just cold like
it's just it's like a still cold but the
hawk is I think when you get whipped in
the face yeah okay yeah all right so
Warren and I have one of our late-night
talks last night and we decided that
there's going to be two things that are
gonna be coming in next week's pod one
of them is going to be weighted EDS are
and the other thing excuse me is going
to be a predictive model so we were
talking late last night and I said you
know what happens with your early down
success rate because I feel like every
week we do it it's like oh you know what
they still like Buffalo from earlier in
the season can we do it to more recent
you said let me run my models and we'll
start that up next week which is awesome
and then the predictive model is more
about what teams do like if they run on
first down what are they doing second
down and now you believe is a good time
where you feel like you have enough data
points to almost be able to predict what
coaches are gonna do right right exactly
the predictive model basically looks at
what was the prior play and then what is
the next play so I can take a look at
what teams did the prior play and then
what they're gonna do next place so
perfect examples number one if they run
on first and ten what do they do on
second down if they throw an
incompletion on first and ten and are
faced with second and ten what do they
call on that play
so some coaches just have a knack for
being goober conservative making
inefficient play calls and the other
thing I can look at beyond just well
what do they call I can actually look at
you know what's the efficiency of that
so if they called past this is what
they're doing if they called run this is
what they're doing and one of the worst
decisions that coaches make and I see
time and time again is they have a
running back get a 1520 yard explosive
run you know he's working through the
line he's working downfield busting his
ass as hard as he can because he sees a
big gain and maybe the end zones in
sight he gets tackled they come up and
call a run play to the exact same
running back it makes no sense this
guy's tired he just expended himself he
fence is tired bringing a new guy let a
different guy carry the rock we can we
we call that the Billy O'Brien special
yet Billy Bob with that in mind I've
always now that you're saying it I mean
do you believe that NFL teams might have
people that do predictive analytics like
working with them on game day because if
I was a defensive coordinator and I knew
that after a run on first down that this
team not only threw it but I could also
figure out you know where they throw it
on second down at a 78 percent clip do
you think that that information could be
processed in that forty second game
clock and really in that five to ten
seconds just to go hey 70 percent pass
on this down and do you think defensive
coordinators offensive coordinators
mainly defensive corners would want that
it would definitely be valuable and
useful but I don't think any of that
exists right now in the NFL I don't
think they're rotten they're models real
time spitting out information back to
those guys but there's definitely some
live in game coaching for the offensive
coordinator and for the coordinator that
I've been working out a little bit
behind the scenes that I think would be
extremely valuable and useful for guys
any because I got noticing right now
unlike NBC does this a lot on their
broadcasts will they'll go if they got a
touchdown if they get this fourth down
win probability goes up at all that
stuff and so I imagine that NFL teams
when they're making crucial decisions
fourth downs goal to go situations
they're looking at those percentages I
just wasn't sure how pervasive you think
in game analytics and models are right
now in the NFL in terms of decision
making not very hmm and do you how much
like what are some things that you think
could be integrated into the NFL that
like if you were gonna make a pitch to
an NFL to
they should do yeah they need to
incorporate they need to do a better job
of self Scout I don't think team's self
Scout enough during the they focus on a
lot during the bye week we saw it like
Julian Edelman go out and talk about we
need to be self sued a lot of self
scouting this week for our offense try
to plug some holes like I look at self
scout all week long for every single
team that I'm assisting I'm looking at
what they could be maximizing on there
and in addition to the matchups and the
weaknesses of their opponent mmm so
you're saying really it's not just about
running predictive models on your
opponent and seeing what they do it's
often turning that around and going holy
crap when we throw on first we run on
second way too much and getting becoming
less predictive as what you're saying
well not not just the predictive
play-calling but just in general like
what are we good at you know certain
teams like they might be doing a lot of
three-step drops from shotgun and and
the quarterbacks actually much better if
he just zero two step drop from shotgun
if they're if they're like so and
nothing to do with like what the play
was before but but certainly that's a
factor too well there was one team that
apparently self scouted and maybe it's
just because a personnel impact happened
and that was cream hunt coming to the
Browns the much beleaguered Browns on
this podcast and every other really
media publication ever but on this
podcast we've talked a lot about their
obsession with three wide receivers and
their inability to go heavy well Kareem
hunt came back in and we saw a wild
swing from the Browns that led to a win
at home over the previously six and to
Buffalo Bills they go from running you
know a lot of one running back sets to
now a lot of two trying to get Chubb and
Kareem Han on the field at the same time
and it looked like it was a lot more
successful what did you see when you
kind of dove in and do we think now that
the Browns have turned the corner
because hunt is now playing I think it
gives them the freedom to not use the
fact that they're both of their tight
ends are not that great as a handicap
say oh well we can't use two tight end
sets you know the the analytics that
like Warren is looking at on
and sharing with us like that those we
can't do because we don't believe in our
tight ends in this situation now you got
two backs and what having two backs
allows the team to do is not simply just
use two backs all the time and call
running plays but when those guys are
out there it causes confusion for the
defense they don't know exactly if it's
a pass or if it's going to be a run one
guy goes in motion one guy split out
wide the linebackers are having to
figure out who they're going to match up
on and everything allows Baker to have
more time in the pocket where the
personnel numbers that different one oh
yeah they were they were using so when
they pass the football they were passing
the football out of 11 personnel only
32% of the time wow this is like a 90%
team earlier in the year yeah they were
up at 92 92% the first couple of weeks
they hit 89 percent against Seattle they
hit 89 percent against Denver so
absolutely this was a team that was very
high on that scale and even from a
running perspective they only ran the
ball out of 11 personnel 26% time the
lowest mark of their season they were
using 21 which is the two backs one
tight end set they're also using some 20
which is two backs no titan-3 wides out
there so they were mixing and matching a
lot of different groupings and it
definitely was helping their efficiency
numbers against the bills again we're
recording this on Thursday Browns play
the Steelers on Thursday night so we'll
see if the Browns continue to do that as
you listen to this podcast I wanted to
look at 2019 and some trends I wanted to
do some self scouting of our own and now
that we're going into week 11 we're in
the double digits and we're making a run
at the playoffs and we can kind of see
what are the trends right now going on
and the first thing I want to talk about
is you're seeing something in the NFL
right now that you haven't seen in a
very long time and that is the home road
splits of quarterbacks what is happening
this year that's different than any
other year mohnish tonight it's it's
crazy it's crazy and this just goes back
to what we were talking about previously
with the lack of home-field advantage
home field advantage disappearing what
we are seeing is quarterbacks that are
on the road actually across like five
different metrics whether its yards per
pass attempt whether it's explosive pass
success rates whether its overall
passing success rates whether its passer
rating whether it's touchdown to
intercept ratio they are equal to or
better than quarterbacks at home which
is shocking I mean I haven't seen that
in any of my years covering the NFL so
it's definitely an interesting trend
which plays into why our teams on the
road covering the spreads better and
performing better off not gets back to
something we shared a 33% the very
beginning of the year home-field
advantage is not worth as much as it
once was and when you look at the
numbers that gets kind of to the next
point which is some of the trends I have
them here in front of me number one
unders are coming in more than overs
this year we're at 51.4% unders and this
is Warren was running his numbers last
night there's not a huge difference
there and understand overs with unders
to have a slight advantage home
underdogs which is something that you
know anytime you're raised by people
that liked to gamble they'll go it's
always good to find a home dog well
guess what home dogs are covering forty
seven point eight percent of the time
that means those road favorites fifty
two and point two percent of the time so
in a weird way right now Road favorites
have been a better bet than home dogs
but then we get to the wild one which is
home favorites versus a road dog and
we're seeing something home favorites
are covering only 40 percent of the time
that is right Road dogs right now are
60% of the time covering the spread and
Warren have you seen this in the last
5-10 years no this is the the the rate
at which these teams are covering the
spread is the largest in any of the last
30 years so it's a three decades we have
not seen roe
dogs cover at this rate which currently
is 60%
correct nothing nothing like this
nothing like this at all and and so ok
so I have some of the notes here so row
home favourites are covering only 40 the
second lowest in the last three decades
is forty four point two I mean that's
four point two percent even that is a
huge margin of a gap like this is super
outlier status right now super
absolutely super on your right like
there's been four years in the last
thirty where the like lowest numbers
that it had been prior to this year was
forty four percent that home favorites
covered the spread and now it's all the
way down to forty percent so it's a
complete outlier what's happening in the
NFL this year for sure so here's the
note though that I think people they
hear a data point and then they cling to
it so right now there are a hundred
percent of our listeners I would imagine
that are going through the spreads right
now and they're circling every single
Road dog and they're going it's a
historic year they're covering it at
sixty percent clip I'm jumping on this
train this week and I think from someone
like you that does so much work and
looks at so many data points I would
imagine this is the part of betting that
becomes frustrating because people want
one nugget and they base everything off
of that one nugget and you're sitting
there going get more data points can you
express that for me please yeah the hard
part is like it's it's this quick
society everybody's got a short
attention span everybody doesn't have
time to dig into everything they want
like what is the trend like give me the
trend that's gonna win like I've been
hearing one recently where it's like
prime time unders have been rock solid
and then like I would have like when I
watch that video you know what
interesting primetime unders I'm gonna
might jump on this wouldn't you hear
that what do you think I think good luck
that's not a winning strategy long-term
just because a certain small sample of
games that have occurred in prime time
have gone under the total there's
nothing special about the fact that
these games are going it's it's not as
if like because it's a nighttime game
that all the sudden the football won't
travel as far and passes are more likely
to be dropped there there's no logical
explanation for why prime time games
have gone under except for there's a
small sample size certain teams are
playing in those games that are more
challenged defensively and the games are
playing out more likely to go under now
the one element that you do have to
consider is the fact that when you got
prime time games lines maker does tend
to slightly inflate the point spread to
favor the action that he knows is going
to come in so he knows more people are
going to want to bet overs so what he's
going to do is he's going to play a
little bit more jacked out line up
slightly but it's only marginal it's not
as if it's enough to just say I'm
blindly betting every single prime time
under because the lines makers over
inflating this by multiple points it
does not work that way whatsoever so you
can't just look at one data point you
can't look at one statistic even EDS are
which is like the bread-and-butter
statistic you can't just look at that
and say oh only betting their best DDR
matchups EDS are match ups because you
may not be taking into consideration
injuries quarterbacks and a multitude of
other things that's why winning at
sports betting takes a lot of work a lot
of effort it is not easy it's why I'm
sitting here from like 8:00 a.m. until
2:00 a.m. with my odd screen sitting
right here and five other monitors so
six in total and I'm sitting here inches
from them all day long with very short
breaks it's because this is a grind this
is hard it's not easy to be successful
betting sports for a living your edge is
very marginal so you have to work your
ass off and you can't just look at one
thing and just try to beat Vegas based
on one little mess so and I get messages
from people that tell me that certain
referees are like Oh innate to the or
like eight in a row to the under stuff
like that and I get so excited I call
all my friends and we put money on it
because we feel like we found this one
there's this thing more in the betting
community called the tip you get a tip
from somebody you enter it right away
because there's just something about
getting that little nugget and that's
the hardest part man cuz when you feel
like you have secret information even
though it's one data point you feel like
you've conquered the world like you feel
like you got a map to find the the
national treasure you know what I mean
yeah and and look being able to handicap
referees it is useful okay how you do
that
it is it is useful there are certain
things that we have looked at in the
past based upon I'll just put it vaguely
game locale the example that the league
wants to try to showcase to a larger
audience or a different audience certain
referees not not just the individuals
but like the league itself does not want
there to be a lot of penalties right so
it certainly you can look to those
trends historically and factor that into
what you're doing certain crews and
referees you know when they get to the
postseason they change it's like the
all-star crews so it's very with these
this umpire and these other officials so
that's different but during the regular
season you can pick up on some trends
certain guys might call more offensive
holding than other crews and so that
legal hands to the face I know where
you're going so let's just go there
should we might as well mention him okay
so I did get a tip from somebody and it
was I don't okay so I it's interesting
cuz I kind of want to bet this tip but
so this is gonna come out after the game
actually cuz he's doing Thursday night
his name is freaking Clete Blakeman and
Clete Blakeman loves to call penalties
and if you look at the trends right now
I believe he's eighth note of the under
and I also believe that he's like
something like Tennant like 92 to the
underdog I fide texted it to you I have
to see what it is cuz I didn't know we
were gonna go here right now but he was
also the dude that called the illegal
hands to the face on the Lions remember
that game everybody said they had the
game and it suddenly went the other way
and so this is a guy that I mentioned
him to Warren
and Warren goes oh there's a folder on
that guy I had no idea I don't think
people know this but at the same point
or and we're Outsiders so it's okay to
say these things right please okay
yeah Clete um look I tweeted this so I'm
okay with one ain't no unders this
season eleven and two two dogs against
the spread mr. cleek baked Blakeman this
guy has been the worst official that I
have seen in the league this season by a
margin this guy is the most frustrating
so we were on the lions against the
Packers fortunately he didn't cost us
the cover buddy sauce money line that
was the multiple illegal hands to the
face plus a few other calls that were
made that worked against the Lions in
favor of the Packers and everybody was
up in arms after the game including the
crew including the crew they couldn't
understand John Perry who was the ESPN
like official in the booth he didn't
understand what these calls were so
Clete called that game and then two
weeks later Clete goes over to London
actually was three weeks later
Clete goes over to London November 3rd
that was actually the last game that he
did I don't think he called the game
last week but Clete goes up because he's
calling this Thursday game Clete goes
over to London and has that ridiculous
call that I tweeted out and literally
got like three million impressions on
Twitter where coleus Campbell goes to
try to tackle deshaun Watson and goes
right next to him like doesn't even hit
him like his elbow his forearm hits
deshaun Watson but his head his
shoulders just completely missed him
because the Shawn slipped of past him
and they threw a flag saying lowering
the helmet and and hit to the head of a
defenseless player some nonsense like
that and the replay clearly shows in
rich eyes and was like what are these
guys calling ridiculous everybody who's
going on so it's not as if like you and
I are the only ones who can't say this
Clete Blakeman sucks he sucks and this
game you know I don't know what's gonna
happen in this game and I don't know if
the trends are gonna continue moving
forward but this
and efficient as in official he's not
been seeing things clearly and I just
don't like watching games with him and
the reason being is this so I hope
Thursday Night Football games great
I want consistency yes handicap games
I'm trying to watch games I'm trying to
work with teams
I want consistency you can be a guy who
tends to call a little bit more of this
you could be a guy who tends to call a
little bit more of that I don't love
that i but but at least don't be so
inconsistent with some of your calls
what I really would love is league-wide
everybody knew what lowering the helmet
and hitting a defensive player was
league wide everybody called the same
way hands to the face league wide
everybody called pass interference the
same way but especially in a game you
can't have unfair scenarios one way or
another that definitely cannot happen
the guy that hooked me up to this
information is Michael Oksana sh a
little you UMass Amherst kind of guy so
if he's if it hits this week man I'm I'm
betting on Blakeman but I think the
reason I think cleats gotten away from
it warm for so long as one his name is
Clete and there's something about seeing
his name on your screen where you're
like oh cleat second is I don't remember
if you remember the first bad lip
reading NFL that blew up which is when
air Adrian Peterson was like orange
peanut for me it was like like just like
a video that everyone loved about the
NFL cleat has one where he's like I want
to put room full of beanbag chairs and I
think that like because his name is
cleat and because he was in that video
and because also like every referee
somewhat looks alike we've kind of given
him a pass but when when we started
reminiscing about all of the games that
he's done and how all of them from the
Detroit game and on to the London game
where there's been I go wow those were
my least favorite games of the year and
the way they were called was so muddled
and there was no game flow at all it
made me realize wow there's a little bit
of truth to this again I don't want to
live on one data point but they have so
much control of the game
that it does it does raise a lot of
questions for me it really does
I mean look he's an attorney it's not as
if he's not accomplished it's not as if
he's unintelligent and you have such an
issue that they have other jobs but yeah
sure right yeah so so maybe full time
guys maybe guys who dedicate a little
bit more to their craft I think part of
the problem with officiating has been
the fact that all these other networks
are springing up and the way in it I
love I love how you just said like an
attorney as though he has like the moral
judgement of like a judge you know I
mean like definitely you know attorneys
I think about it like what the [ __ ]
attorney
okay I'd actually don't trust it no I'm
just kidding they they the the fact with
Clete and I'll just sidestep that one
entirely the thing with Clete is that
there are issues that I don't I just
don't like inconsistency and I'll just
go back to that and we can move on but
hopefully he gets back on track I've
seen him in years past I didn't recall
him being this bad but there's
definitely it's frustrating when you see
games consistently with him in it that
have problems like this so right now I'm
gonna do a little transition I'm gonna
go from one CB to another CB so we're
gonna go from Clete Blakeman to
circadian biorhythm you know because
that's the natural transition of topics
you mentioned this to me and I went I
have a hundred percent heard of it I
would say the most popular I think this
is a version of that is the West Coast
team playing the one o'clock East Coast
game is that also circadian biorhythm it
is yeah but teams have obviously
adjusted in and out I feel like the West
Coast team playing the one o'clock East
Coast game is the equivalent of saying
like always been a home dog like it was
a really good piece of advice in like
2004 but now like teams have adjusted
but I had never really heard of the East
Coast team on the west coast and because
we have an instance of this on Sunday
Night Football with the Bears going to
the Rams it is an interesting thing and
you pointed out just a trend
was existing that we need to kind of
keep our eye on because for since the
the CBA there's been a huge advantage
for the West Coast teams yes
so the issue becomes when you're an East
Coast team and you're going to play on
the west coast in a prime-time spot so
it's like 8:30 kickoff something around
that nature any of the primetime games
when you get to like the second half of
that game it feels to your body like
it's ten o'clock right you're on East
Coast time it's a three hour time zone
difference the game kicks off at 8:30
your time that second half is starting
around 10 o'clock and and not that
players don't smell the salts and get
jacked up and play all the way through
the the difference is not that the
difference is that the West Coast team
that ten o'clock time where it starts
the second half is actually 7 o'clock to
them so just from from biorhythm and
just from a mentality like a mental
perspective they feel earlier in the day
they're used to it being earlier in the
day they're a little bit more awake in
tune with things their bodies are
reacting slightly differently and every
little edge helps when you say that that
affects all 53 players like if all 53
players have a small little minor
infection of impact of this then that is
going to total up and so certainly it
was a much bigger factor at one point in
time that you could really look to that
issue and say I like this dog that's
coming from the East Coast playing in
primetime but man I'm a little bit
nervous about this biorhythm thing yeah
but I mean the numbers themselves are
crazy yeah look what the home team's
were straight up I could say it right
yes ok home teams so on the west coast
when an East Coast team would come and
play them at night in primetime there
were 37 games in between 2011 2016 and
the home team won 31 of those 37 games
31 and 6 straight up and they covered
the spread 67 percent of the time I mean
this was close
work were you just over that time Warren
just being like and that's a cache and
that's a cache like were you be able to
take advantage of that oh we definitely
were able to take advantage of it also
what it allowed us to do oftentimes is
steer clear of some of these dogs it was
just like I said we tend to play a
little bit more underdogs just by our
style especially favorites in prime time
like we're talking about overs it tend
to like increase that line a slight
little bit so we're trying to steer
clear a little bit more of some of those
favorites looking a little bit more at
some of the underdogs and then when you
come out with something that says you
know we we like this team you like the
matchup we like the VAT added value
however hmm East Coast team now it has
changed since 2017 the home teams in
these situations are six and ten
straight up five nine and two against
the spread if you look at what's
happened so far this year Browns went
west coast to the Niners got stopped 31
to 3
Steelers went west coast to chargers
every game with the Chargers all six of
their losses have been by one score or
less and the Steelers pulled that one
out so it went against it but there's a
number of reasons one it's a small
sample size since 2017 maybe teams are
adjusting their sleep schedules but as
you said that's probably highly unlikely
that they would go to that step I just
we don't have faith in NFL teams like
that or it could be what we've been
saying recently which is the home-field
advantage is also beginning to dissipate
more in sports but it is an interesting
nugget and it may come into effect with
the Bears going to the Rams on Sunday
night yeah that's the team that it
affects it definitely has been
compensated for small sample size could
be the explanation as to why this is not
no it's no longer something that you can
bet on and I've said from the beginning
you can't just bet on a one single trend
anyways so it would be a situation where
okay I normally would take this dog
hammer this dog because I love the
matchup and value here but I'm gonna
reduce it from one unit to 0.75 because
of the uncertainty with the biorhythm
issue so that's typically what it was
but it's been compensated for
potentially um it still is probably
slight edge to the home teams though out
west I think what you just said there is
great
if you guys out there you're a $50 game
better your $100 game better maybe
you're a $25 better you're taking in
these little data points oh I like this
whoo you know what I don't like that
they're traveling out there you don't
have to bet the same amount every game
guys like your again we're trying to
find what 1% of your bankroll is and
that's gonna be your unit and you're
gonna kind of figure it out but like you
can bet less on a game don't always look
at the money line the parlay and go yeah
but if I if I hit this I make that much
more it's if you're doing this have a
strategy to it also one other nugget
before we get to Edie SR that I want to
say is this is just something that I
noticed if you go on to Warren's website
let's say you signed up for the emails
let's say you signed up for the service
and I don't think I'm speaking out of
turn here games over spreads that is
Warren you have people that work for you
for props right oh you're not doing like
the prop bets no okay but you but you
have people that you trust rich rebar
and all those guys and and they do it
but you are only doing lines and spreads
and totals exactly in years past
I dabbled a little bit in props I
enjoyed doing it but this year with more
responsibility that comes with working
for teams I am moving away from doing
the prop bets and I brought on some
other guys who are taking care of the
prop ups bets for me so sides and totals
those are me on the site anything from
the betting side of thing is me the prop
side I've kind of resourced a couple
other guys who I like I okay let's move
to EDS R and again we're gonna start
next week doing weighted EDS are just
because me and Warren we're doing some
self scouting and we're like we continue
to get these huge margins we continue to
get teams that maybe we're not that sure
about and to be honest we looked at all
of the matchups this week two mismatches
and it's a very weird week and so we're
like let's adjust our own models but
this week we got a look at it I also
watched Warren get very defensive
because he did say before last week even
though Indy has a knee dsr advantage
over Miami because the injuries to the
quarterback the wide receivers he would
not recommend
so while EDS are went to and to
straight-up last week he said I would
have never submitted the cults so I'm
gonna give that to you and say that it
is two-in-one which means that on the
year it is 16 and 4 and that means also
that last week it was one in two against
the spread the other ones that the Rams
were not able to handle it against the
Steelers the Ravens obviously handled it
big time over the Bengals and the Bucs
got the win over the Cardinals but they
did not cover against the spread
obviously Indy is that okay did I handle
that all right for you and your precious
adsr you you are correct I'm super
competitive and I did not like the fact
that we were going to be counting that
yeah I'm glad you took it off but I was
okay if you were gonna keep it on we
were gonna change it moving forward if
there's a game the reason for the Colts
obviously is their whole season their
statistics were earned by a different
quarterback most of the game ad t white
Hilton now listen you take away you're
down to your third string quarterback
effectively entering camp you're down to
no toi Hilton Paris Campbell's injured -
who are you throwing the football - and
of course Miami trending in the right
direction no Josh Rose in that hurt them
at the beginning of the year right now
it's Patrick it was just like two EDS
stars heading in different directions
and so that's why I would have no I mean
that point spread was a little bit
ridiculous we probably should have been
on Miami in the first half last week
that was one that we definitely missed
and I'll say that's why that's why we
had a conversation last night and I was
like man we got to move to waited so
we're gonna do that moving forward but
let's look at this week number one the
biggest matchup you have by a margin
over 40 it's the it's another one that I
don't know if you actually like Buffalo
over Miami and Buffalo in this game is
favored by six but this kind of feels
like two teams going in the right
directions so a great czar Warren Sharpe
would you like to submit this as an
official EDS our pick Buffalo because
Buffalo is the same we will submit it
because Buffalo is the same in no other
game Indy was totally different kind I
am he was different here we're still
dealing with Miami and Miami is
definitely
trending better ignore EDS our because
again it's just one data point let's
talk about this game just sure I can the
reason that Miami doesn't have as big of
an edge I know there two-and-oh the last
couple of games and trending in the
right direction is the way that you beat
the bills as you've run on them and
writing em II traded away Kenyan Drake
there other running back has hurt they
don't really have the ability to run the
ball very effectively here and we know
that their defense is kind of mediocre
obviously last week their defense didn't
get exposed because you're dealing with
a third string quarterback with no wide
receiver so it was difficult to expose
that defense I think the bills are in a
pretty good spot here I don't know that
I would advocate laying six points on
the road in Miami but in terms of being
able to win this game it definitely
would really surprise me if Miami put a
third straight win together I won't put
a pass Ryan Fitzpatrick he hates you
know he loves going up against teams
that he used to play for and proving
them wrong so you know the bills are a
team he used to play for he'll pour it
all on the line the guy's a true gamer
and I love the grit that he brings to
the table but I won't yank this one off
just because of Miami and I'll say this
so Buffalo last year went to Miami and I
believe it was a yeah they lost they
lost in Miami last year they've lost two
of the last three years to what one year
they won it was by a very close margin I
will say though that I feel like some
teams underestimate Miami and because
Buffalo has already played Miami and was
losing in the fourth quarter and it was
like a Ryan Fitzpatrick interception in
the end zone away from maybe even losing
that game outright I always wonder
because it's a divisional game and
you're definitely not gonna take Ryan
Fitzpatrick lightly that maybe it's a
different situation but Buffalo has not
had that much success down there in
Miami so it's definitely a big line for
a matchup like that
yeah it is again I'm not laying the
points with my with Buffalo this week
but it's it's it's an interesting game
for all the points that you just alluded
to it's funny a lot of the teams in the
AFC East that are familiar with going to
Miami still tend to struggle there
sometime
well it's because they live in Buffalo
and they're getting a free night in
Miami and so when you when that's the
situation live nightclub sounds like a
pretty good spot cuz they don't they
have Dave & Buster's
I apologized all of our listeners
Buffalo I'll come out there one day
second biggest advantage is the super
injured San Francisco 49ers over the
Cardinals and the Cardinals right now
are 11-point dogs here is the injury
report
George Kittel I believe is already out
okay Joe Staley gonna be sidelined a
couple of weeks with surgery on his
fingers because apparently he broke all
of them Emmanuel Sanders is looking like
he might be back but Matt Breda is also
out this one from a very healthy Niners
team to a very injured Niners team out
of nowhere and they're 11-point
favorites over Arizona another EDS our
mismatch that we weren't excited to see
to be honest no really really not
excited to see this I think that the
Arizona Cardinals are trending in the
right direction I believe we spoke about
on your show last week how the Cardinals
for the first four or five weeks we're
using way too much 10 personnel way too
many for wide receiver sets they made
some modifications are using far less a
little bit more 11 personnel which is
the standard 3 wide receiver sets it
puts a tight end out on the field can
help the offensive line a little bit I
think the way to attack the San
Francisco 49ers is spread them out run
the football a little bit and that's
exactly what the Cardinals can do well
the Cardinals I will say this David
Johnson looks done I mean this I don't
know what what like these running backs
is why you say you know you got to be
careful about running back yes remember
two years ago two three years ago this
guy I know he's sustained some injuries
but like night and day
taking the league by storm one of the
best running backs in the NFL one of the
best fantasy producers in the NFL and
all of a sudden it is a liability for
your offense to hand him the ball he has
zero speed
he has no burst he can't get to the edge
they really need to face him out of
there
I feel bad because he's like an amazing
guy he's one of those guys that was
phenomenal for them when none of the
other pieces on that team were ready to
go and they probably gave them the ball
too much and this is my fear about say
Quan you know these years really don't
matter why not rest him a little bit
because I agree I'm looking at David
Johnson trying to turn the corner and
I'm checking the roster to see if Adrian
Peterson's on the roster that's how slow
the turn is and if you knew David
Johnson that man could jump cut with the
best of them I mean he looked like what
the new prototype running back could be
and it's gone but look this is a Niners
team that eats out the win over the
Cardinals we saw Andy Isabella's 88
yards I've talked many times on this
podcast about how if Tevin Coleman
catches that they could win by 17 he
drops that they only win by three but 11
points with an injured Niners team it
just it seems a lot more'n it does I've
heard that there are some some groups
that are going to lay it with the 49er
some already did lay a little bit really
Niners but that's not for me you look
the 49ers could cover this they could
have a bounce-back game
I think Kyle Shannon is a tremendous
coach I do think that he's got a big
edge here over Kliff Kingsbury but the
way to attack this Arizona Cardinals
defense is through the air they're
terrible against like 12 personnel sets
anytime you make it look like run
I don't think Matt Breda is a massive
loss but they are without him but you're
without your top two pass catchers if
Emmanuel Sanders is not there and we
already talked about your missing your
stud George Kittel like it's going to be
very difficult for this passing attack
to really exploit that big weakness of
the Cardinals defense I I would be
surprised if the 49ers lost this game -
truth be told and there is a great
chance that the pass rush can take over
and snuff out the car in those offensive
line and really put Kyle Emery on his
back and we also haven't really seen
many games where a team has a second
lick at this Cardinals offense and I
think they learn a lot that's why rookie
quarterbacks tend to tail off
just for the listeners low sharp school
rookie quarterbacks tend to tail off a
lot at the end of the season and that's
because the book is out the book is out
defences know what these guys are doing
defenses know what the play caller's
trying to do so it was great that
Kingsbury flipped things up a little bit
yeah using as much 10 personnel but you
know the 49ers have seen him a couple of
weeks ago and are gonna be very prepared
here I think yeah if you take away that
88 yard catch from Andy Isabella which I
know is annoying to a lot of people to
just remove stats but the rest of the
game every other Drive caller Murray
threw for a hundred and fifty three
yards against this really good Niners
defense and has everybody right now I'm
seeing a ton of clips of Cuyler Murray
on Twitter and you have to remind
yourself he did that against the Tampa
Bay Bucs
and there's a lot of quarterbacks in the
league right now whose highlight reel
against the Bucks is their defining
moment Cuyler Murray
Daniel Jones Teddy Bridgewater they're
the team where if you want to look like
you can throw the ball the Bucks are the
team so it is one of those like Niners
coming off of a loss Kyler coming off of
a really high performance if the line
wasn't 11 if I got it like six and a
half I would like it a lot more but that
line is so big and there are so many
injuries it makes it tough 30 Dias our
advantage did you have anything to add
after I said all that
no Rams big old adsr advantage over
Chicago you then combine that with a
little Sarkisian biorhythm you also
combine that with the fact that Mitchell
try Biscay had three touchdowns and
everyone's like oh look three touchdowns
no interceptions but it was three
consecutive drives at the end of the
second quarter and the beginning of the
third quarter and they did nothing the
rest of the game against a Rams team
whose offense looked inept against the
second-best defense in the NFL right now
and the Pittsburgh Steelers again this
is looking actually like a nice little
sweet combination with the fact that the
Bears are six and a half point dogs am I
getting too excited about the Rams here
Lauren sharp yeah I don't think you're
getting too excited because it's a big
number
number one laying six and a half points
for a Rams team in their current form is
not lovely
sure that would cosmic and they just
lost their starting center they just
lost their starting center their
offensive line already was in shambles
and you are still going up against a
good Bears defense for dealing with a
number of injuries themselves
defensively they were without a team
Hicks and and they still are and they
just lost one of their best defensive
play makers was the linebackers name
that they just lost who the Bears yeah
slip in my mind is a daily Trevathan yes
to wreaths and they lost he's gonna be
out for a few weeks his elbow like went
back right so he's gonna be out so I
think the issue becomes with those guys
a lling right could the Rams take
advantage of that run the football a
little bit more when you look at what
Chicago is done and where they've looked
good like where Chicago has looked good
so far this season
you're gonna pinpoint games against the
Detroit Lions and I'm going to pinpoint
the game against the LA Chargers where
they should have won against charters
but they lost but the thing is in those
games
the Chargers ranked 26th defensively the
Detroit Lions ranked 25th defensively
the Rams are a top 10 defense they
actually ranked fourth in efficiency
metrics right now they are trending in a
positive direction thanks to the
addition of probably the best cornerback
in the NFL I think that they should at
home here be able to perform pretty well
and limit what the Mitchell true Biscay
and there's whatever they are right now
is going to be able to do so yeah
absolutely the EDS are is in favor of
the Rams
I don't love it because I'm down on the
Rams philosophy offensively now that
they don't have Brandon cooks they
really don't have anybody to stretch the
field so that injury hurts them their
offensive line is a total disaster and
we're finding out what happens when you
allocate so much money to a running back
who can't even run the football
successfully effectively and for any
type of volume like Todd Gurley and
you're dedicating a ton of CAP money to
Jared Goff and he's not playing like he
was last year nor at the level that
you're paying him
yeah again it's funny how many times the
Bears are in a game where I go up its
the regression bowl it's bears Chargers
up it's the regression bowl its bears
Rams it's and the thing is is that the
the Chicago finds a way to lose those
games the only game that Chicago's won
recently was against Jeff Driskel let's
not forget that the fourth biggest EDS
are matchup was the Browns over the
Steelers that was Thursday Night
Football and we've already spent time on
that I'm telling you we just didn't like
the mismatches here number five was
Colts / Jaguars and you went not gonna
use that one
there's too many injury questions which
Jacobi / set there's too many injury
questions with the wide receivers and
it's and Nick Foles is coming back it's
a cloudy situation the sixth one was
Cowboys / Lions again we're sitting
there going is Stafford gonna play what
team are we getting here and it's off
that you said it's off the board right
now yep it's at the time we're recording
this on Thursday early afternoon number
7 is Saints / bucks and I'm looking at
that one and I'm going man this is
looking like at the the time for the
Bucks get to get the revenge here it's
in Tampa Bay where Tampa Bay has really
had an advantage over New Orleans for
much of Drew Brees his career there
Andrus peat their starting guard is out
for a few weeks with a broken arm
Lattimore might be out with a hamstring
now again the Tampa Bay secondary is a
mess but as Drew Brees gonna take
advantage of it so it's another one that
were kind of all over the place on yeah
I think Michael Thomas is gonna dominate
like he does every week but did you
watch I came like Alvin Kumar did not
quite look as bursty and as himself in
that game last week I didn't feel like
you know their their offensive line it's
gonna be a big issue as you mentioned
when you're going up against that
defensive line the only thing the Bucks
have going for them is their defensive
line at least on that side of the
football and you're going up with a
beaten-up offensive line
drew Brees obviously is playing as a
pocket quarterback he has historically
struggled a little bit on the road so I
definitely think that there's gonna be
some potential issues there and if you
don't have a lotta more and you could
take advantage of that as long as Jameis
can stay upright that's a thing when I
went back and rewatched that game where
they played the Saints earlier in the
year right
week four or five the the bucks we took
the bucks caching I think three and a
half in that game and it was three not
four four it was Teddy Bridgewater and
not Drew Brees but they were catchy like
three three and a half sorry 3 and I 4 4
and the Saints punted I think the first
drive and then for like eight different
drives they either they had one punt in
that range and it was either touchdowns
field goals or turnovers like they
really were moving the ball effectively
on the stampin Bay Bucs defense and one
of the big issues was probably I mean I
know this because I bet on the game but
Carlton Davis that bucks
act was ejected from that game for like
a ridiculous hit I felt like some of
those calls in that game because it was
in New Orleans we're going pro New
Orleans with all the stuff that's
happened with the referees in the past
they ejected that guy and the defense
completely fell apart and that was
really like on the second or third drive
of the game that he was ejected from the
game and Carlton Davis missed last
week's game it's one of the reasons why
I was betting on the over when Arizona
played the bucks last week is because
know Carlton Davis he's practicing Carl
massive is practicing those guys both
might be back who missed last week's
game so the Bucks defense is gonna maybe
look a tiny little bit better than what
they did in the game in Tampa sorry in
the game in New Orleans earlier this
year there's definitely not one where I
would be looking first to lay the Saints
I'm actually looking at going the other
direction on that one potentially to
that point the last of the last three
times New Orleans and Drew Brees have
gone down to Tampa they're one in two
and also the let their one win was the
last time they went which was last year
they started that game off down 14 to 3
so the Saints have gotten off to some
slow starts their last three times in
Tampa and Drew Brees really has not
played well his last three games in
Tampa 201 245 to 57 and a 2 to touchdown
for interception ratio and he's only
been sacked four times but now without
Andrus peat and an offensive line that I
just saw get dominated by the Falcons if
I was gonna go one way I'd go Tampa but
you know how I feel about betting on
Tampa and Jameis Winston
yeah he scarred you probably more than
anybody else that I can recall this
season it's it's tough it's not fraying
that cleat Blakeman was the referee in
the Tampa Bay Saints came you think
there's any chance it was I'll tell you
one second I've got his uh his game log
pulled up here hold on he's if it's
freaking him I'll lose my [ __ ] no it was
enough who was it that came oh you can't
find it all right I all could pulled up
yeah I don't know okay all right let us
move then to the biggest games of the
week and we'll start off first with two
teams coming off of a bye close to my
heart Eagles Patriots Belichick loses
before the bye to Lamar Jackson now has
a week to get ready for the Eagles the
the Patriots for the most part are
healthy right now they do have a few
people that were limited but they're
also starting to get some people back
need Abner missed practice Patrick Chung
and Matt Lacoste
and Danny Shelton did take the field
overall they're healthy Philly right now
al Sean and Nigel Bradham did not
practice Jordan Howard and Jason Peters
were both limited they're coming off a
two game winning streak over Mitchell
true Biscay and Josh Allen so the bills
and the Bears where do you want to start
here ly I would like to start with the
Eagles defense and Tom Brady okay so
think back to the Super Bowl where the
Patriots
I don't think punted one time okay so
I'm gonna throw some things out to you
that you're not gonna like as an Eagles
fan oh this is the gym shorts gym Josh
McDaniels matchup yeah it's not gonna be
pretty
so Jim Schwartz I believe the numbers
show that he is averaged allowing 35
points per game when he's played the
Patriots when he's been the defense
coordinator 35 points per game now we
were talking about a number of years
right and Jim Schwartz the defense this
year has trouble in the secondary but
this is not the same Patriots offense we
cannot kid ourselves whatsoever here
Dantes Carnegie
has his work cut out for this offensive
line they're a bad offensive line right
now they're struggled to keep Tom Brady
clean they are also a team without much
of a deep threat I mean when Mohamed
Sanu is the main guy who's working down
the field for you you know you're in
trouble they will get a little bit more
integration with sinew off of the bye
week I think so that definitely helps
but it's not the explosive team they
also don't have the dynamic ability with
their tight end because Gronkowski's no
longer there and they really don't have
many tight ends so their personnel
packages like the potential personnel
packages have slimmed down a little bit
it's narrowed in terms of what the
Patriots offense is able to throw at Jim
Schwartz but just know that historically
has not gone very well for schwartzie
one of the things that I'm interested to
see when we're talking about this side
of the football is the matchup when the
Patriots decide to go up tempo they call
it their turbo package they go fast and
they chose to go fast against the
Baltimore Ravens last game out and look
at the number variance between these two
when they huddled up they had a 46%
success rate when they went turbo that
improved to 62% when they huddled up
their passes were only 45% successful
when they went turbo that increase to
58% and when they huddled up their runs
were only 50% successful when they went
turbo that increase to 73% Wow they said
they couldn't implement even as much
turbo as they wanted to because of
injuries and not everybody on the same
page well they just had a bye week pal
they just had a bye week theoretically
they got a little bit healthier and they
could do a better job of getting on the
same page so one of the best strengths
of the Philadelphia Eagles is their pass
rush than their defensive line and if
you're the Patriots and you can somehow
reduce that rotation and wear down those
defensive linemen I would think that
would be in your best interest to do so
so I'm curious that's the first thing if
we're talked about that side of the ball
is yes the Patriots have not really
played very many good
teams the Eagles definitely have a much
better defense than what the Patriots
are accustomed to playing but secondly
the Eagles could be in for trying to
deal with a speed up-tempo package of
the Patriots so you just told me that
Jim Schwartz has allowed 35 points per
game against the Patriots you just told
me that the Patriots have been wildly
successful speeding the game up
increasing the play speed getting more
plays in and then after a buy now
they're gonna be more healthy but
Belichick is clearly gonna look at this
because he's the one guy we can bank on
doing this and likely implementing it
more so the only thing that I'm doing
right now is I'm looking at the total
which is at 45 and I'm asking you on the
other side of the ball or the Eagles
gonna help me get there or could this be
a one-sided affair well see that's the
interesting part the Eagles I would
assume their offensive line is a little
bit healthier they've had issues with
Jason Peters at left tackle and they do
have some issues though at some of their
bigger positions I know that their
number one running back he missed
practice yesterday or at least Jordan
Howard was limited Jordan lowered
limited and their number one wide
receiver Alshon Jeffery who you can
argue you know he's not the greatest
number one wide receiver you probably
don't love him but he also I think
missed practice entirely due to an ankle
injury and his game status is so
questionable that they brought in Jordan
Matthews and you know when you're
bringing back Jordan Matthews that
you're in a position of weakness you
obviously got rid of the guy because you
didn't think you needed him um my
question is this Warren we know the
Eagles have had success this year
running to tight end sets and pounding
you in the face and the one way that
teams have had success against the
Patriots is pounding them in the face
Ravens Browns Bills we've seen teams
have success can the Eagles do that this
week yes they can
my lone issue is what does what does
Bill Belichick do with McCourty if you
don't have to deal with Al Sean Jeffrey
are you gonna waste him on Jordan
Matthews or you're gonna try to stick
him on one of the tight ends
you know are you gonna try to stick him
on Earth's and what will that do because
that's my biggest concern there but I
would say yes Bella checks number one
thing is what is your number one option
and let's take it away and the number
one option for the Eagles offense is
Zach Ertz
and I would say number two if it's not
Myles Sanders it's it might be Dallas
Cotter
yes probably Shawn it's it's it does I
think it it could be Goddard but like
from a target perspective they're
incorporating him honest lower basis so
he's not really the difference maker in
games but he can make those couple of
plays when you are targeting him to make
a difference but he's not consistently
getting targets so I would like them to
use a little bit more 12 personnel and
throw the football though but more to
their tight ends definitely they should
be able to have some success running the
football I'm going to be interested to
see what the Patriots did from their
self Scout to improve that run defense
but on this side of the ball you know
obviously they've had some explosive
plays I think in five of their last
seven games
take a guess you're the filling right
which offensive player has the longest
play for the Eagles in five the last
seven games
I think it's mild Sanders yep mild
Sanders so he's been super explosive can
they work in a little bit more mild
Sanders into the receiving game to
create some of those explosive plays
here that's going to be super
interesting to me hmm
I don't know yeah well I guess Michael
I'm looking at that game now and the
sides I'm not really sure I would
probably lean towards the Patriots but
as a total I don't know if the Eagles
are gonna help me get to the 45
I can't tell because I think it's in
their benefit to pound the rock
especially to give their defense time to
recoup after that after the Patriots go
turbo
45 is an interesting number there yeah
and if you look at the ball too if you
look at the New England Patriots in who
they've gone up against who was not the
President and not the president of the
NFL Players Association
well they heard me talking about cleat
and I think that's could be Goodell
saying yeah I just got invited to go to
the Kaepernick workout on Saturday
that's what that is
yeah that thing is a
I don't know that thing is a mess but at
any rate with regard to this the
Patriots have only faced teams with
offenses that ranked bottom ten in the
NFL and then they played the Baltimore
Ravens who ranked third so the Eagles
are above average they're top half of
the league in offensive should see
despite all of their problems they Doug
Peterson that style of offense you know
the Andy Reid tree of coaching even look
at what Matt Negi was able to do when
the Patriots went to Chicago and they
had some success pointing up points so
now this aisle has given Belichick a few
problems along the way but it's gonna be
a super super awesome game I mean by far
it's the best game in that late slate
I'm actually glad you and I talked about
this last night my first inclination was
man why are you shoving the Houston
Baltimore game which we're going to talk
about next in this one o'clock slate
giving us eight games there give us some
more at the four o'clock but then we
both sort of realized the rest of those
one o'clock games apart from like a
couple of interesting division matchups
and then the Jacksonville Indy game
which has some divisional implications
most of them are between teams with
losing records are not really all that
compelling the Houston Baltimore game is
going to be the game everybody's going
to watch in that slate and then they're
gonna tune into this Patriots Eagles
game we're got a great Sunday a football
with the marquee games on those one
o'clock and four o'clock yeah because if
those two games were on at the same time
it would be tough to flip back and forth
but the fact that Houston Baltimore it
is the premier one o'clock game it is
the largest total of Sunday right now
it's at 51 and a half and I'm looking at
your website right now and just watching
the lines I believe the over has been
getting bet this morning I'm seeing it
now going up to 51 and a half I think it
was at it opened at 49 and we're already
at 51 and a half and I think a little
bit is it's - Shaun Watson its Lamar
Jackson these two guys fought it out in
college hung up monster numbers when it
was Clemson Louisville there are two
teams right now Houston is coming off of
a bye and I don't think any team is
clicking as strong as Baltimore so let's
go with the the star of the show Lamar
Jackson right now in that Baltimore
offense taking on a JJ Watt list
defense of the Texans and Romeo Crennel
and how do you see do you see Baltimore
keeping it going with their three tight
end defensive tackle playing fullback
sets I see
Baltimore being able to do what they
want through the air in this game I mean
when you're the when you're the Houston
Texans and you go out and you make the
move that they just did in free agency
for Vernon Hargreaves who is like really
not good
he's like 108 out of 115 cornerbacks
based on their passer rating allowed so
far the season he's the type of name
only move that you would make if you're
desperate and you don't really know how
to evaluate guys but you see a former
first-round draft pick and you know your
secondary kind of stinks so you scoop
them up I told you last night this is
like a dance Snider move where Dan
Schneider goes in oh my god I get the
opportunity to take Albert Haynesworth
here and I can get dion sanders I don't
care if they're a little bit past their
prime their name value recognition guys
and they could come in and maybe
contribute here and you amass all these
guys that actually aren't playing well
right now and are past their prime
that's what I get from Vernon Hargreaves
oh the one issue though that I will
caution about Baltimore is the Houston
Texas have been very good against tight
ends one of the best teams in the NFL at
a key I think they're number two and
success rate allowed now hide ends so
the the interesting concept though is
that the way that Baltimore plays
offense it's so unique those tight ends
are doing so many things differently
than other teams that I don't know how
that's going to play out ultimately but
I definitely think that there are some
edges here for the Baltimore Ravens
offensively to attack this defense and
when you think about you don't have JJ
Watt I think this is what his second
game that he's been out cuz they had a
bye last week readiness game against
what was it the Oakland Raiders I think
right before this so you're in a
situation where you're definitely gonna
be dealing with a worse pass rush from
Houston and a worse run defense because
he's actually a really good run defender
so I think those things all are gonna be
chips in the favor of the Baltimore
Ravens and the one thing I will say
about Baltimore from a coaching
perspective is last week was the game
they were supposed to be flat they were
not supposed to show up
means Maddie that was a game that I said
before the season I like this team we
bet there overs we bet their futures we
like Baltimore more than what the market
did that's the only reason you're
betting on something before the season
you think the markets too wrong on that
particular team timeout I think I saw
during this wait did you just move the
Houston line you [ __ ]
I was sitting here and I'm going oh I'm
seeing a lot of movement right now in
the Houston game Baltimore going over
and then I go to your website and I go
to active recommendations and it says
Houston over split take Houston over 24
over 50 I'm giving it away because you
move the line live during this podcast
you son of a [ __ ]
I had to yeah unfortunately because I
got so hyped on it that you were like I
need to put this out right now I
actually look at your smile right no you
were you were talking about it you can
go back and watch this this on tape when
you were talking about the line moving
I had a coy little smirk on my face by
what I was trying to like not showcase
it too much so I can't I am doing a
podcast with somebody that made a click
and then all of a sudden all of Vegas
reacted to it so you got it at 24 and a
half and 50 for the game and I look
currently at the lines so you got it at
50 and right now I'm seeing at the West
Gate at 51 and a half yeah tell me they
jumped up up and it's moving now at the
Bovada yeah Cantor's Cantor is the high
watermark on that one there at 52 right
now now I will say since we kind of gave
gave the recipe away for this one if you
do like the over I would certainly wait
I think there is a group that likes the
under on this game is opposite of what I
think and they will probably bet this
game back down and 51 is a very key
number so I would look to be finding a
51 later and maybe even a forty nine and
a half and take the over later if you're
still interested now the first half I
would not do anything on the first half
that's now
like 26 or 25 at some spots 24 was the
number we're looking for there so I
would not lazing you're amazing what was
the game this past weekend that if you
waited it actually did come down was
that seattle san francisco the seattle
san francisco game yeah that was one
where because we were doing the free
week last week i took over 45 last
monday I believe so a week before the
game even kicked off and that game was
hovering 47 47 and a half closer to you
know game day the couple days before and
I basically said look 47 somewhat of a
key number here I would definitely wait
this thing should drop to 46 and a half
and if you want the over then I would
reduce your bet size go maybe a half
unit on the over at 46 and a half and of
course it did go down to 46 and a half
and a lot fell in our favor late but
that one do tell but it was proof to
what you said before which is if the
number crosses what you wanted and you
go and you're like oh I'm gonna bet this
and it went up a point and a half it is
worth it to wait as it gets closer to
game time cuz most people will even it
out but you just a lot of people like to
set it and forget it you know to quote
Ron Popeil and they like and I get it
but it's the value how you have to wait
for it I I do that - I hate it the worst
weeks for me the most frustrating weeks
for me are when I am waiting on a game
I've got the game loaded up in my system
I'm ready to send it out we're ready to
bet it and it's Monday it's Tuesday and
the line isn't right where I want and I
think that there could be some under
money coming or some over money come in
so that I can get a better number later
and I'm having to wait on a detailed
write-up and a good men like all the way
until like Sunday during the day you
know that's the worst for me but gotta
get the good number man you got my
offshore place at 52 now in Houston
Baltimore you're crazy
you're a monster alright anyway back to
this game you were saying you were gonna
look up Romeo Crennel versus mobile
quarterbacks do you have something on
that I don't have anything on that yet
but when I do when I get to my write-up
I'll definitely have some good
um what about the other side what about
Houston and DeSean Jackson against a
Baltimore defense that they've been
putting up points let the last few weeks
whether it's Humphries or Peters they're
scoring points on that side of the ball
which is great for overs but what about
DeSean how do you see them attacking the
Ravens Dee that's the scariest part of
this game because I don't really know
what the Baltimore defense currently is
right now their secondaries playing a
lot better if you are betting a game
over the total you sort of want DeSean
to be trailing because that's when he
gets more dangerous and he's pushing the
ball down the field a little bit more
often we'll see if we'll fuller is back
for this game I assumed that he was
going to be out but if he actually does
end up playing here which I think he
practiced on a limited basis that would
be a big boon for this total and for the
Texans offense in general the one thing
that I that stands out to me a little
bit is that the Baltimore Ravens ranked
number 30 number 30 defending running
back passes and you got Duke Johnson for
the Houston Texans as a safety valve for
deshaun Watson the other factor here is
that the Baltimore Ravens ranked number
27 in pass rush so their pass rush isn't
really getting home
it's one of Jim Harbaugh's I'm sorry
John harbors real frustrations with the
team for a number of weeks so if they
can't get home on Watson and that's the
weakness of the Houston Texans is their
offensive line if the offensive line
could give him enough time and when it
doesn't he could throw the ball to his
running back so those are the two
weaknesses of the Ravens defense he
could be in a pretty good shape and the
other thing here too is that the Ravens
ranked 28th stopping the run and that's
another element where the Houston Texans
ranked number 12 in rushing efficiency
I've been surprised by Carlos Hyde and
what definitely I definitely didn't feel
like he was gonna be quite as good but
Baltimore they're off what is it what
did I just say there's 20 against the
run
despite playing the second easiest
schedule of run offenses over the last
four weeks I start looking at this this
time of year they're trending defense
they weren't dead last in the NFL over
the last month stopping the run and
guess who they've played the freakin
Cincinnati Bengals twice the the Seattle
Seahawks and the New England Patriots so
I'm looking at this as a team where I
think Houston possibly could run the
ball a little bit if the Shawn has a
little bit of time in the pocket if he
could throw the football to his running
back you know it is going to be hard the
challenge will be throwing the ball down
the field but the other thing I love
about watching this game two mobile
quarterbacks and you you know this Adam
but when teams have the ability to get
their quarterback to like avoid that one
rusher how many times have you seen a
game where it's like this guy's open
down the field the quarterback might be
able hit it but he asked to pull it down
and then he gets sacked because there's
one free rusher who's on him but if that
quarterback can avoid that dude a bunch
more stuff opens up down the field and
both of these quarterbacks are capable
of moving in the pocket to still throw
the ball down the field just like
Russell Wilson is they're not just
moving to run they'll get those free
yards if you're going to give it to them
but they're looking to still throw the
football down the field so it's
definitely a game where I think Houston
could have some success that's why I
don't think this is the slam dunk that
everybody thinks taking Baltimore lay in
for four and a half I mean very much so
Baltimore could win this game and it
could be a fun exciting 17 point win at
home but there's certainly the
opportunity for the Houston Texans to
take advantage of some of those
weaknesses of Baltimore's defense I do
think it's interesting just because with
Houston coming off of a bye teams coming
off of a bye this year like we said are
not doing well Rams came off of by last
week didn't go well
Saints came off a bye granted was
against the Falcons team coming off of a
bi but the better team coming off of a
bye there fell flat on their face I
think teams coming off of a bye last
week went one and three and so you have
Houston and there's a huge coaching
mismatch in Harbaugh versus Billy O
Brien and Romeo Crennel
I believe there's a big special teams
advantage to with Baltimore but the
thing is is you bet against people like
- Shaun Watson again at your own risk
because there is nothing better than
having Lamar Jackson and deshaun Watson
on your side as you attack the over but
if you're betting against deshaun Watson
those last few minutes of the game are
gonna feel a little bit hopeless because
that's what he makes defenders heal and
that's what you'll feel I think if you
bet that bits a
tough game it's a fun game though it's
gonna be a great game to watch I
couldn't agree with you more a hundred
percent on everything you just said I
think I think it's exciting
my question is Kansas City Chargers we
didn't prepare for this at all I'm just
gonna ask you quickly because I know we
got to go Monday Night Football the fact
that it's in Mexico City how does that
impact the way that you look at that
game just from a location standpoint
well you know we had the issues with the
field I think the field is in much
better shape this year we were gonna
play there were so many concerns about
at the end up moving the game to LA as
their home game last year the Chargers
have been practicing at elevation in
Colorado Springs and Anthony Lin said
I've talked to experts and they say it's
not going to help us it doesn't matter
you got to be out there longer than just
a week to get prepared but I don't care
I've played in games where I went from
sea level up to elevation and it
impacted me and you know what I say to
that kudos to you Anthony Lin I'm glad
that you are taking some of your
personal experiences and working towards
using them in a manner to make smarter
decisions it's not pure analytics but in
elixirs about using data to try to make
more educated decisions I'm glad he's
doing that for the team and even if it
doesn't physically help them all that
much mentally that's a big deal it's
going to give a lot more confidence to
this offense and to this team in general
my biggest factor for this game is I'm
really concerned about this Chiefs
offensive line we got to look at the
practice reports there's a lot of
injuries going on with this Chiefs
offensive line already have a
quarterback who looked pretty good
better than I thought he was going to
but he does have an injury it is
probably not quite a hundred percent and
you don't want him taking a lot of licks
back there the other thing about this
game on the flip side the way that you
beat the Kansas City Chiefs is by
running the football on them we've seen
the Titans do that we've seen the Colts
do that they've got a good past defense
it's not the same past defense as we saw
last year so the problem with the
Chargers is they're one of the most pass
heavy teams in the NFL so they're going
to have to switch their attitude and
strategy and try to rely more on the run
game and hope that it's
efficient with Melvin Gordon hoped that
he's back and can churn out yards up so
that's gonna be interesting from their
game plan and stride back did for sure
the first thing I thought of was okay
you just told me that when there are
some games that are more high-profile
that a game that's in another country on
Monday Night Football is definitely high
profile and that referees in those games
tend to call less holding penalties and
so maybe that's an advantage for Kansas
City to handle as we like to call in
this program the program which is Bosa
and Ingram and you know if I hear that
the Chargers throw a lot and Patrick
mahomes I start looking at the total and
I go okay I mean if you do is a big
number but maybe maybe the fact that
it's an a big televised game will allow
the the teams to get away with some
stuff to allow more points to go on the
board just a thought
yeah I don't have anything right now on
this total it is kind of a big number it
could be warranted if these teams try to
use a little bit of tempo especially we
saw the Chargers implement they're one
of the slowest teams in the NFL but
there were a couple of periods with
their new offense coordinator that they
did actually use a little bit of tempo
and had some moderate success I mean
let's be honest Philip Rivers just like
ill you know what but one of philip
rivers the only thing he does well is
when it is hurry up and he's calling the
plays he can then he could like dinking
dunk and move it but what he's running a
straight offense it's awful if you can
hurry him up I would do it I would do
hurry up just from the simple
perspective that the play clocks not
gonna be three to one with it I've been
like a madman behind Center each knock
on it seems like that's like that's
really the thing I'm gonna remember most
about this guy but he's useful at rivers
this is Philip Rivers in a nutshell
doesn't come in darn it rips rips the
front the chinstrap off goes to the silo
and they like blames other people and
it's like dude you've been doing this
for a decade and you've been changing
the plays you're running around you're
trying to talk to this guy house talk to
this lineman and tell them this little
tip like just freakin call the place so
if you can do that and and get the snap
off with 15 seconds left 12 seconds left
big advantage for the offensive
coordinator for the Sandy
la chargers for sure if you have
subscribed to sharp football analysis
good for you I'm sure it's gonna be a
good week again he already gave out see
if that line goes down at all with
Houston and Baltimore that's when you
want to take it because we're recording
earlier today we cannot get to crack but
again as always check out the crack
winds app I love the interface I love
using it I think it's an easy way for me
to see the spreads and I like to see
what cracks free pick is and as I've
told you before college basketball is
when crack goes crazy this is an NFL
show so we're not gonna break it down
but that's where he finds the advantages
so definitely check out my man cracks
crack wins app sharp football analysis
calm if you're checking it out awesome
and as always you can hit up warren on
social media at sharp football I am at
Adam left Co if he has any more nuggets
follow him on social he'll put them out
there Warren you're the freakin man have
a great day
anything you want to say to the homies
before we leave just you're clear the
hawk fellas steer clear the hawk and if
it's brick the hawk is coming see you
guys